Can you name two monarchies outside of Europe?
So other than Europe,
two monarchies anywhere in the world.
So in 2024. Go ahead.
Saudi Arabia.
Yes, exactly. Oh, okay.
There's a bunch in the Middle East.
Next to Brunei.
Brunei. Brunei.
Nice. Brunei.
Good job. You got Brunei.
Good job. Thailand.
Thailand. Yes,
exactly. Thailand.
Where the king spends too much time in Germany.
Yes, that's true. Yes.
Uh, Bhutan. Bhutan.
Yes, it is Bhutan.
Impressive. Nice.
Are you sure about it?
Yes. No. Bhutan.
Absolutely. Yes.
He's kill you.
It's not Malaysia.
Malaysia. Yes.
They have a rotating monarchy.
United Arab Emirates. Yes.
You got it. UAE.
The Amir. Guitar.
Guitar. Yes. Jordan.
Uh, Jordan, yes.
Is a monarchy. Yep.
They see the entire Arabian Peninsula except for Yemen.
Okay. As a monarchy.
There's three in Africa.
Can you name any of the monarchies in Africa?
Swaziland. Swaziland.
Eswatini. Nice.
Starts with L.
An L. The Soto.
The Soto. Nice.
Exactly. Yes.
And the Morocco is the other one.